what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today don't worry darling the movie
starring Shia LaBeouf and Chris Pine
spit yes
I don't think we're talking about this
movie at all in this channel but it's
out on HBO Max so you know it was like
people already be asking us like you
guys going to cover it so yeah I figured
why not let's do it Harry Styles can do
no wrong even if he's awful in this
movie we will not say that no no anyway
guys uh please go ahead leave a like
John how are you I'm ready to go to
Harry's house how are you I'm ready to
go to Harry's house too I understand why
Olivia did it and yep I understand why
anybody goes to Harry's house also uh
full-length Reaction watch Longs We sync
up with your own copy of uh don't worry
darling available for a super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page over there
we cover many things exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch along as
they included thank you to all for
showing your support by following us
over there lastly this video is
sponsored by wondery one of our go-to
podcasts it's always exciting to work
with a company when you already use
their services but we'll talk on them
more right after the reaction let's get
to the reaction
[Music]
does this take place in the past uh yeah
I guess it must
[Music]
romantic Donuts
how many people I'm gonna be at this
party because I need to know how much
tuna salad Frank doesn't like tuna baby
why didn't you tell me I was planning on
it being the centerpiece to my dish oh
it's not the centerpiece I still feel
like they're 17 years old
playing older
you forgot your tuna Jack oh the tuna I
prepared the centerpiece
[Music]
there's cheap stuff for her husband I
guess at home and privacy whatever
floats his boat maybe that's his kick
so they're all forced to take
ballet classes some kind of Stepford
thing remember
late in control there is Grace in
symmetry
is that the the theme of the movie the
theme of the movie
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
Jenna
[Music]
smack her ass toots
[Music]
people said this movie's predictable
I have no clue what's going on same
[Laughter]
whoa
what
he bought the magician's egg carton damn
this couple is so into each other how
could you not be there the two hottest
people in the world I made a roast
house mashed potatoes
not eggs
[Music]
oh what a bunch of [ __ ] dude you
just oh
oh I've heard about this scene
[Music]
I've gotten much older you have ruined
the food
so I know you got a spoiled life here
but this all costs money it took time
yeah if you watch this on YouTube you
you know though
yeah really see that
okay you have to stop humming that song
what is it I don't know I was hoping you
could tell me it's been stuck in my head
for days maybe it's a children's song
some of your kids sing Oh no I don't
have children shame
what is your purpose in life
well once you have one it's all the same
as how many babies should Violet have
okay something's not real yeah this
whole life is hollow and empty like
those eggs and they don't even care
about the food
literally just ignore the food on the
table I haven't really gotten to talk to
Frank very much Frank doesn't have to
talk to you
oh I'm sorry I didn't you have no idea
how extraordinary he is or what he can
do you're lucky to even know who he is
let alone be standing in his house oh my
God
Frank has built something what he's
created out here it's it's a different
way
a better way and we only have each other
why are we here
thank you
we shouldn't be here we're like one of
the only ethnic couples on your mouth
shut you know how hard it was good
Margaret's question is right it is the
good question to ask why the hell are we
here
I don't know man just stand our ground
to look harder to dig deeper to mine
that pure unbridled
potential that gem
of Limitless and unimaginable value you
guys look like all you do is have fun I
see greatness in each one of you I know
exactly who you are
what are we doing changing the world
what are we doing changing the world
that's right
freaking Nick crawls
oh
they're hiding me suppression pills no
nothing is fine she just needs to sleep
I don't sleep
I have bad dreams
oh
the 50s give her a smack
Sean Connery the before you lose the
decade man
and then it becomes unacceptable
gonna happen like every 10 minutes yep
every new location every new costume
[Laughter]
keep it going Chris likes to watch
oh my God what is going on
what is going on hey uh so she knew how
dangerous it was just like we all do the
one thing they ask of us is to stay here
where it's safe but still she dragged
that little boy out into the middle of
God knows what
you gotta go there Florence Pugh so when
they found her
she was alone they never found him I
knew he died I
just hadn't realized she claims they
took him to punish her
what is this like is this area 51
development of progressive materials but
sometimes Peter insinuates that they're
actually making weapons and that it's
all happening underground because Frank
discovered
it's scary to sacrifice something but
you're sacrificing something more by
sitting in that fear what you see here
what you do hear what you hear here let
it stay here is it a political
commentary on suppressing women I mean
there's definitely a lot of that so far
oh my god oh what
oh my God
you need to drive out there it just
crashed I I can show you where it is
drive it no uh I don't go that way
oh my God what's wrong with you
oh you're gonna get in so much trouble
what if it's the little boy yeah he's
just been out here training to be a
pilot this whole time
Jared Leto's in there I'm just gonna
stop guessing
this movie gives me yeah I don't know
what's happening whatever I guess it'll
be wrong
Jason Sudeikis is in there
with so many divorce papers
cool wow
foreign
[Music]
I like that
supposed to be
nice
are they experimenting on the women
specifically probably
pills and all the they clearly must
control the food how long have you been
home
a few hours
okay
now I guess don't worry darling means
ignore it yeah I got off the trolley I
saw a plane crash because I think it
would have heard if there was a plane
crash no it seems to be rather loud and
I started walking and
um nope he's definitely making making
sure you don't
um
hey
you okay don't worry darling you had a
really weird dream well they're wiping
memories around here man
you love me
the most oh he's been body snatched is
it some like Westworld [ __ ]
we'll never find out now
you're being conditioned programmed
[Music]
is it our covenant
until tomorrow
oh crazy
ouch
this life is suffocating you
ow
e
hello
you saw it
she doesn't know what she saw
I can't talk to you right right now
Margaret no one asks any questions I
would not do this over the phone yeah
they can listen
[Music]
don't question it
she's gonna invent hip-hop
[Music]
oh no oh damn
[Music]
foreign
okay so I guess none of this world is
real
I like the music a lot Zach I got
curiosity and a panic yeah it's like
really eerie and disorienting no
[Music]
Margaret
[Music]
no no you're the only one with answers
no
oh damn it Margaret save her Chip and
Dale
oh [ __ ]
stitches please don't get hysterical
say the title of the movie Jack
uh oh
you know what I do Alice I'm a technical
engineer
what does that mean what do you think
when I asked my mom what she does
understanding for years I don't know
what you do
what does that mean what does that even
mean you know we can't come on what does
it mean what does it even mean
not everyone gets this opportunity and
if you keep talking like this you're
gonna put it all at risk you're worried
about a demotion our life how is our
life together this
we could lose this wow
at least he seems like he actually loves
her in his own weird way in his own very
Randy kind of way honestly I don't even
remember
Frank gave us the opportunity of a
lifetime wow
thumbnail
them clicks oh [ __ ] she didn't even
realize that all what she just did did
she nope not at all oh she wants to
break free
but I was quite a tumble
she was so embarrassed
talk to her it wasn't a tumble
she slid her throat Alice ah no no no
witnessing a trauma can often lead to
distorted memories even nightmares
let's get some gaslighting in here
I have some pills I can prescribe for
that uh I I really don't think that I
need those
they're precautionary
security risk they will just
keep you relaxed
they're bad doctor
let me have my security risk envelope
exposed
this isn't a problem
we can handle it ourselves well I'll
just keep that on file
what did you do
to Margaret you still don't
understand how she's okay you wouldn't
want me discussing the details of your
treatment with my other patients now
would you um
[Music]
she was having significant troubles
outbursts
paranoia she made impossible for Ted to
do his job so he no longer works for the
victory project uh oh a bit of help
not like you
it's not necessary here
it's a totally different scenario what
is it that you Brit say cheerio
Keep Calm and Carry On
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
he left that there on purpose
the yikes
so glad you came back you left this I
forget my head if it wasn't screwed on I
wonder if she remembers her life before
this seems like we've seen a flash or
two maybe but she can she consciously
recall it I bet not
geez it's all redacted
nothing
[Music]
it's probably just all in code final
warning
[Music]
might ask Shelly to dance at some point
if it feels like a good time
you look incredible or like she was just
drowning
that's how I like my lady
that's a really impressive shot
oh nice
that's good if they're like some type of
alternate reality and her her real self
is she let her sick and see through into
it and are trying to communicate to I
wouldn't put it past it maybe maybe
we're in this maybe we better explain it
I
you enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
so Dina Von tees she's a burlesque
performer now so she can't be playing
herself I guess but
[Music]
you are the ultimate product of this
place
keep it together
keep it together keep them together Keep
Together Jack Chambers
whoa I could have you up here for a bit
oh so did uh they watch like mid Samar
and say yeah get Florence Pew to do
something kind of similar here but like
you know in Palm Springs sterile desert
50s land let's do that this man is out
of the ordinary this man I am in awe
Jack Chambers I am honored to invite you
to join our senior Advisory Board wow
but he's just a boy and we got Big Ideas
he's gonna spit on you Chris
what's wrong what's wrong
[Music]
uh Alice she's going down the road
that's why I asked earlier what her name
was is I was like is it directly in
Alice in Wonderland yeah
she didn't slip it wasn't an accident I
saw it happen I saw her fall they're
lying about everything
[Applause]
[Music]
and so I went out there and I saw it you
went out where
careful if you can't trust anyone man
and when I touched it I saw something
and I keep remembering more no I would
not trust her but you are behaving like
a child
your husband is out there having the
most important night of his life
he's being celebrated and you're in here
trying to rule
exactly like
and the cycle hums
I'm ready for an awkward dinner oh yeah
let's get it going ask all the questions
Alice
I learned something very exciting oh
really what's that rumor is you and Jack
are trying
well
we'll see we'll see a little boy
it's a man's world I'm sorry bunny
didn't believe you
[Music]
but then again you didn't believe
Margaret so
why should anyone believe you
oh that's cold no great man has changed
the course of history without being
pushed to the limits of his potential
[Music]
and you push me
I do hope you keep going
uh-huh oh God
uh oh look at her walk
it or walk Oh no just get this
conversation going people
thank you oh
man
Violet where are you from
Philadelphia
I'm from Philadelphia are you serious I
didn't know that you know I liked most
the women here from Philadelphia yep or
Baltimore or Chicago ever noticed you
got another thing I for one do not miss
the winter
yeah she's figuring it out what was the
last Beach you went to beaches are
actually some of the filthiest places in
the whole world just a Sandbox of
disease do not say disease they need to
know I could probably guess Hilton Head
Cape Cod or the Jersey Shore they're all
given a background
yes
right oh wow you were breaking the mold
cool
that's how they met yes that's true I'm
jealous honestly it's such a smart story
yeah yeah
laughs
he's using all of us do you even know
what the veggie project actually is have
you ever asked do you
is that why you went out there
no oh
yes I did go out there and I went to
headquarters and I saw what he's hiding
he's lying to us he's lying to all of us
about what the victory project actually
is he's trapped us here trapped I hope
no one feels trapped do you feel trapped
no one's answering directly yeah tonight
you've trusted us
in your home just like I trusted you in
my bedroom
what's in this world let's talk about
that where did it come from oh I'm sorry
everyone let's just think about it I'm
sorry you should clarify what he was
implying about the better of first yes
your husband's not to think of something
else yeah
that's a pattern isn't there a pattern
of selfish pampered whining or is it
just a desperation to be exciting
so manipulative well I won't listen to
your pathetic ranting any longer Well
Jack I think you may have over served
your wife
oh yeah now it's your fault bro Jack
let's talk
played your hand go to the desert take
the car we need to leave and we can go
anywhere we can go anywhere and we can
create our own world and it will be you
and me and we'll be okay and it's not
about where we go it's just that we're
together please please
I was acting off her I'd just be like
wow she's doing such a good job
she's really carrying me through this
scene right now
I'm so lucky
oh no
this is not an okay this is an okay to a
different decision
you're just gonna go down on her again
hey that's what they're working on a
victory it's just a giant pleasure wand
I wonder if this is actually the modern
day oh is it is it gonna be uh spoilers
for The Village I feel like they are in
some type of Westworld type of thing
programming that they keep experimental
programming baby what's wrong all right
so I had to keep this from happening
what
baby we need to go we need
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
the [ __ ]
[Music]
squeeze out of tear
oh yeah here we go it's MK Ultra time oh
my God look at the nurse
oh no no
I could withstand this
sorry
oh yeah maybe it is modern this looks
very like that looks modern day yeah
[Music]
oh
are they giving her a lobotomy oh oh
I had a feeling from the beginning that
it was modern day okay
well it'd be nice to know that so he's
not British
you know I there was a moment at the
beginning of the movie where he was
talking with a brief American accent and
I was like what what's up with this I
was like what's his voice yeah what's
this accent and then call the guy he
couldn't come today but I'm really tired
baby that's me no Jax just stop I just
finished a 30 hour shift I sewed up 12
people and I gotta be back in six hours
and I'm so tired I just need to go to
bed 30 hour shift you think you're
running a YouTube channel with that kind
of hours
and almost as important work almost
that that is the real you
I know that you are the man you say you
are Bond the ideal man all the game yeah
that fantasy stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
that's why he puts on the British accent
so they're trying to create a new
Society yeah I'd like it how do we join
oh my God
it is the most beautiful sign I've seen
in my life did you hire professional
artists to paint we made it ourselves I
would love it if Olivia Wilde knows the
truth and she chooses to just stick with
the what this The Narrative is I bet she
I wouldn't be surprised
hi
it smells amazing thank you
I'm here for my food and sex now well
you're a little early but I have
so many things to finish
so I'm gonna need to go put things out
of the oven no it's gonna burn
yeah there are things about
Chris Pine's character that feel like a
cult leader meets Jordan Peterson yeah
yeah that was a good call do you
understand the discretion required to be
a part of this community yes do you
understand the consequences and
discretion
are you aware that you are responsible
for preparing your home device system
this is Regency Shia LaBeouf yeah yeah
do you consent to the physical and
mental requirements for entry to Victory
metaphysical where you are responsible
for the physical upkeep of your chosen
life ew
are you aware that you must exit the
simulation for victory headquarters
every day and return home for draw a
live number of hours yes
[Music]
miss you so they are in a simulation
yeah yeah this is the real modern right
now
yeah because it's the red
okay yeah okay yeah
I guess we were right
[Laughter]
welcome to the victory project yeah it's
all a big simulation two active users
wow your re-entry has begun
into what we know is true to hold you
they don't need food
maybe you're having another episode just
take a deep breath
it's okay
[Music]
think about your life and what you
actually want
huh
don't tell her that dude it's not gonna
go well for you she wants Freedom make
her own choices she wants to live in the
real world things that modern day
women's though
I have to leave every day just to make
enough money to keep us here and I
[ __ ] every minute of it I [ __ ] hey
Alice
you get to stay here
and you're happy
let's hear good intentions
right uh right it's the way to view it
definitely and definitely definitely
we would all do this
to you and you made me feel like I was
in crazy
[Music]
I'm sorry now's not the time to go down
that fixes everything
the cheat code a man's responsible for
his own wife and nothing else
so all the wives are trapped here yeah
you didn't pick up on that reverse step
after Olivia Wilde yeah no I need it
[Music]
thank you thank you everybody
what the [ __ ] is he doing
got the glass yep
oh
Alice
if you die in this simulation do you die
in the real world excellent question
the Mind cannot live without the body
what happened
I was listening to me
no I need to tell you something funny to
leave no this world isn't real they're
gonna kill you Frank created a program
and he created a world and it's yep yep
exactly Alice a man dies here he dies in
the real world Jack can't put you back
in this time he can't put you back in
like oh my God this is becoming an
action thriller let's go let's go stop
some bullets
buddy your kids aren't real they are
kids aren't real they are the real thing
is they're real to me Alice because here
they're alive
yeah yeah
Christ Alice who whose blood is that
Jack go back inside Alice sweetheart
stop where is Jack oh Mur them all yeah
ah
[Music]
that's right they all know deep down
they know
go
go let's go
hurry up yeah well you still can
foreign
I love how these virtual reality
programs have to get into the car yeah
[Laughter]
it's a little predictable guys I'm still
really enjoying it yeah
I like this a lot for the most part yeah
oh
she's the she's become the bond
character yeah
[Music]
what is about to happen
like chicken
nice
that was clever well done
good sir listen to me you do not let her
exit
oh
yep
he's stupid
[Music]
oh my God
what you have done is started a
revolution
Liberate the women
[Music]
like fire ants yeah
God running Barefoot on that yeah dude
I know she has like fake feet a little
hobbit feet
hurry up
don't buy it
oh is she gonna choose to stay here she
better not
no
oh what okay
what
[Music]
uh oh no go go go go go go go go go go
[Music]
oh thank God
once we acknowledge that reality reality
reality we can let go
go
[Music]
it's gonna be over now right
color's coming back
[Music]
beam me up Scotty
[Music]
[Music]
I disagree
there's a lot to be worried
exclusively things to worry about
[Music]
okay well it's over now
[ __ ] to talk about yeah that was
enjoyable yeah I enjoyed it I don't uh I
don't understand the Guff this gut I I
unders what I heard I heard that there
was um
a divisive ending
so when I thought she was going to stay
behind was I was like oh that is
[ __ ] yeah because I was like I heard
it was a device defending or something I
don't remember what Rotten Tomatoes said
if they said something all right yeah so
now I'm like is it just divisive because
of the do you mean like yeah the the
reveal is divisive or is it the actual I
mean I I I watched it play out and I was
like I don't understand what the problem
is yeah I'm not upset really by any
other by any of the uh you know place it
chooses I mean no I I think the movie
perhaps they're up on Rotten Tomatoes
but before that
a word from wondering
thanks to wondery for working with us
again and sponsoring this video and yet
again for introducing us to another
fantastic podcast one that I didn't
expect to be saying is a fantastic
podcast because it's a show that I was
like kind of up and down about over some
episodes that we really didn't like and
there were some episodes that we really
liked and a couple that we actually
quite loved it was such an up and down
Journey but this podcast from the first
episode alone made me go wow I already
appreciate this show that much more and
that is the official the Lord of the
Rings the rings of power podcast first
thing they took me about this podcast is
that it's host by Felicia Day many of
you guys might know she's like one of
the most Ultimate Fantasy nerds out
there I personally didn't know about her
until she was introduced in Supernatural
where I thought she was great in it on
this podcast ago Episode by episode
through the whole season and they
interview Talon from in front of the
camera to behind the scenes for example
the first episode is with I don't know
you're probably a very small risk Clark
I believe the actress who plays
Israel she always pronounces the correct
two on the podcast yes while listening
to it I was like wow you know what I I
like this first episode that much more
ready and I like Galadriel that much
already because I started to understand
a lot more of the insight and the
approach due to the fact that Felicia
Day from both just being a fantasy nerd
but also being an actress as well just
gets the best questions in there yeah I
really loved it you're talking to me
about the finale recently yeah they also
had JD Payne and Patrick McKay who are
the show Runners on to break down the
finale and they talk about other
episodes as well across the series it's
fascinating to know because there's been
so much made out of what they have
access to and what they have to work
with you know hearing what their
reasoning was for why they guided the
season the way they did and just the
human elements of being there day to day
and you know making this insurmountably
big production is fascinating stuff
really I would say that if you enjoyed
the rings of power you're more than
likely going to love this podcast so
please give it a shot even if you were
kind of just like sort of we were in the
middle if you were like us to me it made
the viewing experience of the Rings of
power that much more rewarding so you
know as they say here to go into the
canals of Newman
watch the rings of power on Prime video
and listen to all eight episodes of the
official the Lord of the Rings the rings
of power podcast for free on Amazon
music you could download the Amazon
music app now I did that so join me on
that Journey Don't forget to check out
the Wonder app or subscribe to
wonderyplus in apple podcasts for more
they're becoming like the go-to center
for my podcast so thank you wondery for
working with a loyal customer all right
here we are the ending isn't for
everyone
but the cast especially Florence Pugh
helps don't worry darling make the most
of his story with fairly few surprises
yeah
Chasm between the uh the critics and the
audience and I and I would I would be
with the audience on this one I would be
with the audience on this one
because it's an enjoyable it's I enjoyed
it I like the I like the tone I like the
world the first like 30 minutes
especially reeled me in enough to the
point where I'm like I don't know what's
going on but I want to know yeah you
know I wanna I wanna understand what's
happening and
you know things did start
once you start piecing together pieces
of this that feel derivative of other
things you've seen yeah then it starts
progressively becoming like okay I'm
figuring this out before the movie's
telling me what's happening I'm figuring
this out you know yeah yeah yeah so it
does become it's not like instantly like
I figured this out from day one from the
second it started there was like some
Clues I don't know what it was some type
of subconscious clue that felt like it
was modern day that's why I questioned
it yeah the top of like oh this is in
the past
um yeah I get what you mean because I
think I think they do wisely in the
early moments to sort of there are
places that do feel a bit Timeless and I
was thinking of Palm Springs because
Palm Springs is a place that's kind of
like that at least in my recollection of
it so yeah I feel like that's that's
intentional and then they do a good job
of steeping you further into the idea
that this must be the past but but yeah
there's something and I think that's a
nice Nuance of tone that is kind of
tricky to strike to get you wondering
are we in the time in place that it's
suggested we're in because something
yeah doesn't seem quite like we are
yeah man like a good Sci-Fi story you
know Matrix is like arguably my favorite
movie of all time I'm really bummed
about the cancellation of Westworld but
there's a lot of other than the Android
part there's things that involve a lot
of with uh my manipulation of the
subconscious reality Distortion and
whatnot and uh you know realities that
are not real in one's own mind and so
it's like there's a lot of qualities in
the way the tone and the editing and the
style of it it wasn't you were pointing
out Under the Skin yeah and it was under
the skin you said Black Swan and one
Alice in Wonderland reference like
there's a lot of things that most The
Village The Village Justice For The
Village yeah there's a lot that feels
very
um yeah derivative of these qualities
but
I don't know maybe if I saw it in the
you know what it is if this got like a
95 percent on Rotten Tomatoes and then I
watched it then I would have been like I
don't know guys I don't know if I'm
there with the critics yeah yeah but
she's telling me 34 and I watched this
I'm like it's not that bad come on it's
pretty easy it's an enjoyable film it's
enjoyable I thought it was really
enjoyable especially because the the
acting from especially Florence Pugh and
Chris Pine who's that's a character who
doesn't have that much screen time when
you think about it but it's the kind of
villainous character whose presence
needs to be felt throughout like you'll
hear them on the radio a lot everyone's
ideologies and their way their entire
way of living is all formed around this
cult leader yeah and who they want to
satisfy and get validity from is from
this dude so yeah I think that was well
done and like Florence pughes
like phenomenal as always like oh there
are Parts
just such a midsummer type of thing to
me yeah if you guys have seen it half
expected to see her covered in flowers
at the very end yes just watching Harry
burn up in a bear's costume yeah and
then you know some of the societal and
modern day political commentary I
that's why I'm more surprised the
audience is
[Music]
so very modern day political
guys who feel emasculated who just want
to transcend their station with their
chosen partner and how do they do that
they go back to the good old days yes
where all you had to do was stay home
honey live your life and I'll go do
soul-crushing work in order to maintain
the illusion yeah I mean there's there's
lots of gaslighting and there's lots of
just the idea the idolizing of yeah the
especially sort of 40s 50s past as being
something idyllic and and when you like
deconstructed is a lot of terrible
things oh yeah yeah we've done more
modern day you know like [ __ ] like Mad
Men that really shows yeah exactly
absolutely and so yeah it's you know
it's again not Illuminating this for the
first time like you said it's it's doing
a lot of things other media has you know
tread the ground of but I thought yeah
this did it with at least a very assured
tone a lot of really good filmmaking a
lot of you know quality performance like
like all the work on display is pretty
quality so like in a weird comparison to
draw but I almost uh in this moment I'm
reminded of um what's the Tom Cruise
Morgan Freeman Joseph Kaczynski Oblivion
uh Oblivion okay yeah uh Oblivion is
like clearly this is derived of many
other Sci-Fi movies however I still like
this whole kind of thing and I would say
that I felt the same way about this but
maybe more so like I maybe like this
more than that and uh yeah like there's
a fair amount of commentary you can draw
on you know especially societal and
gender politics and yeah like especially
the way you have Harry Styles as this
guy who's clearly a bit of a deadbeat
and who clearly wants a better life for
them both they're both struggling they
must have some kind of genuine
relationship but he's you know it's no
coincidence that the fantasy he
ultimately gets pulled into this gift he
thinks he's giving her yeah removes all
of her or at least much of her autonomy
it removes her you know vocation and it
puts all that stuff on him you know and
yeah it swaps it all out for a very
traditional gender role and that's I
mean it may be a bit straightforward the
way it's like you know you basically do
all the work in supporting us
and I wish things were different
um but yeah yeah I mean like for for the
mystery what you think of Harry Styles
you know uh I thought he was fine I
thought he I I kind of agree with the
things I had heard beforehand it's like
I didn't think he was bad I thought
there were a lot of scenes in which he
was good I thought he was uh you know
you really believe him when he and and
Florence pure canoodling I feel like the
most and you know when he's in these
people enjoy those scenes yes yes they
do and uh and and you know when he is uh
in a more power position uh you know
when he's like breaking down in the car
when they're taking her away that was a
moment where I was a bit like okay like
you know maybe get a few more years of
acting under your belt and then you
would be able to really nail a scene
like this so I I see some of the
limitations but I wasn't sitting here
going like oh man why they cast Harry
Styles aside from his status as a
celebrity
um and and it's one of those things I
like he showed up in Dunkirk and I was
like
I'm not distracted by this because I can
see how and why you would bring a person
like him even with his status in the
modern world into a place like that and
what it says about you know who had to
fight that war and also he fits within
that era so then going to another story
that's you know within uh you know a
past 1900s decades aesthetic you know
30s 40s 50s-esque you know Deco uh
mid-century modern things like that like
he fits this time period well uh so you
know it's easy to kind of yeah like
there are things about his boyish charm
and his shiny appeal that lend
themselves very well to this movie so I
wasn't sitting there going like weird
choice if you couldn't get Shia LaBeouf
because then you think of Shia LaBeouf
and you're like I could definitely see
him in the modern day sequences I'm very
curious to see how he would fit into the
fantasy of it all I think he would have
been I don't know if they would have
made him British in the fantasy I think
that would have been very distracting I
find that more distracting than Harry
Styles doing in American
and remembering that Florence Pew is
British doing Americans
yeah
oh my God she's British that's right oh
my God it always blows my mind I totally
forgot that because I I hear her voice
and I'm like that like
um uh is the kind of on a personal note
those are the kind of voices I tend to
be most attracted to Sir sure a little
bit of a raspy yeah she's got a little
bit of that Smoky yeah
um yeah not so much like the
high-pitched voices so uh you know
that's all a woman sound
[Laughter]
yep
they all sound like that it's really
annoying actually Selena Gomez has the
kind of voice that I'm talking about it
yeah she got that wrath too uh but
um what uh wait I I think I think
sometimes it is hard to to look past
some of the
I feel like on my personal end it was
easy for me to look past it for most of
the time and just watch the movie and
not think about those other things other
than a few jokes here and there
uh I I think Harry Styles's performance
made more sense to me once the twist was
once the reveal took place I would like
the more subdued because I think what
you might imagine
what what I think the idea of casting
him would be is that for most of the
movie when you're in the fantasy world
you'd expect a guy who's really going to
fully embody the fantasy and really be
sort of the
the presentation of it all really embody
the presentation of it all the
quintessential successful man in this
Paradigm the the very Charming very
charismatic big personality to then have
a contrast when you see the modern day
and you're like he's not that at all
he's actually those like a pathetic
self-loathing guy that's greasy dude
yeah yeah so I think they want to have
that contrast whereas I think what Harry
Styles was doing was keeping that guy in
the modern world alive in the fantasy
world and that's why I had more of a
sub like every other guy was sort of
buying into the fantasy yeah where he
kept it a little bit more like he was
aware of the fantasy and kept it subdued
so I guess it's really down to him that
that's the I'm not I don't feel like I
agree with the benefit of the dad I feel
like that's what he was doing with his
performance and I I guess it really
comes down to is that choice did that
choice work for the movie or was it kind
of like
I'm not really sure it's like I felt
like there should have been more of a of
a gravitational pull a more of a
magnetism to his performance as I guess
what I was getting at you're supposed to
fall in love with him too yeah and I was
always like he's fine yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's like he's fine he looks good
with her and I get how this relationship
works I'm not in doubt that they would
be together however Chris Pine brings
you're never like fully not suspicious
of him but there are moments where he
brings that like I see what people like
get suckered in by this guy like you
mentioned that Jordan Peterson quality
that he has and uh yeah it really is
leader meets Jordan Peterson asked Meats
yeah because I listened to a lot of
motivational people and I've heard some
Jordan Peterson talks that are good and
then I've heard some that are really
that are that are questions
I'm gonna say all of it's bad but there
are things that I've heard where I'm
like I'm [ __ ] anymore yeah and I feel
like that's a good it is a good standard
well it's not a one to one he's clearly
this guy like it's a good uh stand-in
because I think that's part of the Frank
characters uh deal as well is there's
probably a lot that sounds very
reasonable and very appealing and then
there are those nuggets where you're
like whoa whoa whoa hold on wait we're
going to Extreme Measures for some of
this stuff yeah um but but yeah like
there's with the Harry Styles character
yeah the magnetism I think is a good
word it's it's that's the the Gap that
needs to be filled but I appreciated the
performance what I'm saying though is
that I did appreciate what he did in its
totality once I got what he was really
doing when after the reveal was shown
yeah because within the fantasy world
the part that felt the most real in
terms of a big acting performance was
his ending moments with her
um women they're like fighting it out of
the room where I'm like okay like it was
all sort of like this whole performance
started making sense like the choice
started really making sense to me yeah
the truth yeah next yeah yeah so um
yeah not that it was like a perplexing
but hey yeah I don't want to like spent
too much stuff [ __ ] like that's like
the Harry Styles performance and it
works I think it works too because of
the way the movie captures the
perspective like it it does keep you so
in Florence in Alice's shoes and so from
her perspective that even when you are
in intimate moments with them there's
you're still disconnected from everybody
else yeah so I feel like yeah that that
lends itself to his performance and the
other ones as well well yeah because
there are times where it reads like is
he
green is he withholding Charisma like
when he's dancing and stuff it was it
was like such a weird way of going about
it yeah but then suddenly when you know
the reality you're like oh it's all so
the whole performance suddenly clicked
for me on the choice he was making yeah
yeah you know yeah and uh but no I mean
to me it's like this is Florence Pugh's
movie uh from beginning to end like
she's she's so phenomenal and she's
great it's a character who's like thrown
into a crazy scenario who's walking
around the whole time going what the
hell's really going on yeah it was
almost a reminder at times in ways yeah
yeah which is like another one yeah
just start naming off this kind of movie
I'm the only normal one
yeah
um and and uh and then you know I I
think what Chris Pine does is really
clever because sometimes very overt in
what he's doing especially with the
writing uh but other times there is that
that type of uh sneaky Insidious quality
you know even when he's like drawn to
Florence Pugh it it it's like a
it's something that feels provocative
and not not a a teeny bit
not a teeny bit supportive of someone's
potential yeah
it's something to play more games with
oh sure yeah yeah it's the cat and mouse
and that's why that's why he's like I'm
disappointed yeah when she plays her
hand he's like no I mean I wanted you to
like you know keep unraveling this at a
slow pace and yeah prolong the game and
make it some kind of Twisted
instead of yeah directly you know trying
to wreck this thing I've built for all
my Bros ears yeah I guess the movie's
like not as like
clever as maybe he wants to be in it's
not that revelatory necessarily but it's
really I think it's a really enjoyable
movie and it was fun to play along like
I had fun playing playing along with the
movie you know yeah it captures its
mystery well enough that I yeah I I and
I think you were there always hooked
always like what is going on always a
little on edge always suspect of things
like and yeah that makes it a fun
engaging experience and so I yeah I
would put this in a category with other
films where you're like yeah this didn't
reinvent the wheel but it rolled it with
style you know it rolled it with a plum
yeah kind of like the movie Oblivion
yeah
some people really hate that movie and
then I see it I'm like well yeah I see
what all your Inspirations are that's
fine I still like what you did it still
looks good I would still you know I'm
not champing at the bit to watch it
again like ASAP but I would happily
watch it again yeah see what other Clues
might arise I really thought a movie
like this would get way more hate
commentary of pushing agendas and stuff
because that this is like so 2022. sure
yeah
you've got a sad lonely dudes who just
want to lock their best girl into an old
timey fantasy and run their lives a
woman being oppressed and wanting their
freedom after being chained down by men
and and also and other women helping to
bolster the system you know that these
toxic men have set up yeah you know that
whole thing like and for all the crap
Olivia Wilde has gotten for this movie
like I liked her supporting performance
and that bit at the end is pretty
heartbreaking where like the way she
played that moment where where Alice
like confronts her about like do any of
the other wives know like clearly she is
complicit in this horror and you feel
for her because yeah the whole thing
about the kids like and and uh you know
her loss and that but also the immense
amount of suffering and just the the
events of wronging of all these other
people at the expense of trying to
maintain this fantasy for yourself like
I guess I would I want to understand
some of the other
go back and watch some watch this to see
what some of the intentional choices are
with some of the mirrors that linger or
when
what's the girl's name who cut her on
throat Marlene Margaret
yeah you're probably right Chip and Dale
Rescue Rangers uh oh that's her yeah
I was like I must be missing something
that's the only place I've seen her yeah
she's the the cop they work with
um yeah
is Margaret yeah it makes sense okay uh
like when she sees Margaret in the
mirror like I don't quite get this but
all right
sure I think a uh a mirror like like in
terms of the rules of what's going on
that's not talking about the rule like
thematically it makes sense but rules
wise now I'm like wait a minute are you
doing something thematically that
contract that goes against your rules
now now that I understand this is a
virtual reality program looking at you
it's just a glitch you don't realize
yeah for sure for sure or is this just a
pure pure hallucination of some kind
that just because Margaret is in your
subconscious that's what's showing up
yeah yeah yeah that probably makes you
probably just did it right there yeah
the rules the rules I made up the rules
but yeah no stuff like that stuff like
that is fun to dissect and yeah I mean
you know you have that other bit where
she's in the many mirrors of her bathtub
and then she's got her one face that
doesn't move you know like I I guess
yeah mirrors or the windows to the
subconscious in this movie and then I I
love that bit with I mean like that is a
I think like a pretty overt uh you know
magical style Choice when the wall
presses her up against the glass just
showing how constrictive this fantasy
life has got to break through he's got
to break through the glass ceiling the
glass wall
um
I want to be smart
and try sure I can go
and I can I'm sure I can uh find my way
into it via conversation of
understanding
because obviously the things about like
you know creating the perfect woman with
the ballet but I also didn't fully
I there are parts of me that I'm like I
don't quite get the ballet part that
they kept cutting back to with the black
and white and The Haunting imagery yeah
of it like why specifically this ballet
imagery is the is something I
I can't really articulate it feels like
it makes sense but I can't tell you why
it makes sense there's not like yeah
there's not like one specific explainer
that comes to mind I feel like it's sort
of an amalgamation of like okay it's
very they're talking about symmetry it's
very symmetrical and in that way it's
very hypnotic yeah so you know that goes
in line with the sort of brainwashed
element but also I mean the life that
they are doing here is a sort of
organized dance especially for the women
it seems like because you know you've
got dudes going outside who have to work
and hate their lives for 12 hours a day
but yeah the women are a part of this
weird yeah synchronized choreography
that they don't seem to have any control
over that's running on this Loop and uh
and so yeah okay yeah and I like stuff
like that where it's like they're
cutting to it periodically and you're
like yeah what what is this what does
this even mean and then finally at the
end you're like okay they're projecting
this this is part this is this is
actually diegetic in some way it's it's
in the film
as they go into their hypnosis you know
alternate reality State see I feel like
I picked up on that early in the movie
and then it kind of lost sight of me
it's I think it kept doing like cut as
it kept cutting back to the haunting The
Haunting visual part of it like when
they were actually just doing ballet it
makes sense
but a haunted visual stuff I was like I
don't quite get the the horror I kept
going like to jump like a ballet
background what's going on well that was
actually it's funny I think we had we
had the yin and yang because I was like
okay I think I get with a point of this
you know like old-timey footage they
keep chopping in but you know like they
actually have to go to a dance class
yeah you know like it seems like they
could be doing other things but yeah I
think that's just making that's
following that Motif probably because
they're all staring at it that's part of
their lives now in here is because it's
so in their subconscious yeah we all go
to dance class and we get to have our
Black Swan reference too and I think you
know I'm sure Olivia Wilder to more of
this than people say
I mean I I this is my first I think
Olivia Wilde joint but you know you
haven't seen book smart no oh that is a
hilarious movie I'm excited I want to
see it it is very similar in tone and
style and cinematography okay yeah I bet
and then symbolism two girls who
are having a hard time saying goodbye to
each other ways the oppressive Paradigm
of academic learning of academic
Pursuits that's a funny ass movie that
movie
um yeah no and I think it's impressive
that she can do a movie like book smart
and then put something like this
together which is just such a different
film in every regard like there's not
you wouldn't think for one second it's
the same director and I think it is
really impressive that she was able to
do that and I like everything on a
technical scale from our design
production design beautiful the music is
very haunting I love the music um yeah
it's a great score It's a Wonderful
score
and I think yeah the direction I thought
was was good and
I don't know I feel like there is
something that I can't quite put my
finger on that feels like it's a bit
missing for me in terms of
the ramp up pace of it all I guess I
kind of wanted it might just be a want
but I felt like
I I do feel like it could have gone a
little bit more
anxiety ridden sure you know I think it
could have it could have gone like
mother it could have gone like Black
Swan where it's just like this is
[ __ ] or Superior yeah this is just
like a mad house now yeah yeah lean into
that they did the whole thing with the
blood drop and the eye dilation and I'm
like lean into that like weird Beyond
the Black rainbow like surreal symbolism
like yeah like really go horrific I feel
like if they had really breached the
outer sphere into horror because it's
you know it's a pretty solidly a
thriller of sorts and and two I don't
know if if you would agree but I feel
like you could have maybe done a little
bit more in the grunginess of the
present to make things feel a little
more substantial there rather than just
like oh here's the reveal yeah yeah
um yeah and I think that's part of what
there seems to be a lack of a of an
extra punch to it that it's missing for
me yeah yeah it's like I feel like I
would want to I don't know what and I
don't know if this is quite it but I
feel like yeah in those present-day
moments if it had said maybe one extra
thing in that environment in that
context it might have felt like you said
that thing earlier about this feeling
like one of those movies that thinks
it's a little more clever than it
actually is and I feel like that is kind
of a part of that mixture I'm like okay
cool here's a reveal but you know and
maybe might be cool to get another
revealer or another sort of layer or
Nuance on top of that especially because
it so much of this begs the question of
like what are all these other people not
that we need to see everybody in the
real life but even maybe like seeing
Frank at one point in the real world or
something like that
um yeah I would have I guess it
it feels like it would have been cool
like if she was I think that the missing
beat for me personally
I'm not a big fan of
being the guy who's like here's how I
would make your movie I'm not I'm not a
big fan of that well actually here's how
I would make
I'm gonna go for it do it
um where I was sort of missing for me
was really
the
because obviously it's going down so
like from the very beginning and from
the tiny bits I remember from the
trailer uh that I think I saw like once
in the theaters is that yeah she's gonna
go crazy when everyone else is she's
gonna be uncovering the truth everyone's
gonna think she's crazy when she's not
right and I think like her descent into
going crazy could have hit home harder
and then it could have really had a like
a gut punch when
Harry Styles does not ultimately decide
to leave with her so then it could have
it could have probably helped sell that
when she's back in the world like oh
this is how the movie's gonna end it's
gonna end with her
she's been brainwashed again and she's
back in this world yeah and she's just
plopped there like it's a tragic end and
you can't escape yeah yeah like it could
have sold me on that but I was like
I think the movies just was also aware
that no that's not how it's gonna end so
let's hurry let's hurry through this
mislead and it just like kind of sped
through the time when she's back and it
just went by so quick yeah then it was
like let's get to the part where she
remembers it again I feel like they
could have you could have yeah either
convinced us more heavily of that of the
fact that yeah maybe she is just gonna
go back in and repeat the cycle and I
think you maybe could have
we we all know that by the end of the
movie like we all know she's right that
she's actually and I think that you
could have maybe teased us with like
even though I think we would always know
if you'd at least given us some reason
to go like maybe she is a little crazy
or at least maybe what she's seeing
isn't exactly what the truth is even
though something is off whereas you're
pretty much always certain that she is
absolutely right about what she's been
appearing yeah something that really
does feel like an anxious claustrophobic
mess as opposed to just doing visuals
that represent a claustrophobic mess
something that really feels like that
and it didn't quite give me that feeling
but I was always watching and focused on
like what's going on I want to know I'm
enjoying it and I'm having fun trying to
figure out what's going on yeah but in
terms of the the feeling
I never quite felt what Florence Pugh
was going for in spite of the fact I'm
aware she's phenomenal and exceptionally
believable
I never found myself truly In Her Shoes
I never found a true self as a true
self-doubt in in the performance like I
felt I felt her increased paranoia and
fear of the series
but yeah but pretty much once things
start to feel fishy she is assured I
didn't really ever get a sense of of
self-doubt or you know just the debate
within that comes before you decide no
something definitely messed up is
happening here it seems like she pretty
much catches on really fast which I
don't want to necessarily begrudge the
character for being resourceful and
observant but at the same time for what
this movie is trying to achieve and for
you know again like you said it's
engrossing the whole time and that helps
everything out but there's not much in
the way of like misleading you it's more
just like what truths keep not being
revealed yeah you know instead of oh
I've I've been uh you know swindled by
something
yeah I I do think a performance like
this as much as I kind of respect the
choice that she never really quite goes
am I crazy
as much as I respect the choice because
it's a predictable choice to do that at
the same time I'm I feel like that would
make it more human and would have helped
elevate it and it kind of feels like
it's sort of like a thing like this
sometimes feels like it necessitates the
character really questioning am I am I
losing my mind am I crazy is this is
this me but instead it's it is a very
much a I'm committed to knowing
stop me there's something else happening
yeah well I think they could make the
journey a little stronger if you again I
don't I don't want to take the the
strength of the character away because I
I kind of get the the argument for that
as well because there's so much made out
of the gas lighting that goes on in this
movie so many people are just trying to
finesse her back into the status quo and
yeah I I I don't think it would be
reductive to have at least an instance
where some of that gas lighting does get
to her
in a very focal way and then you have to
transcend and shatter that you know that
barrier like that would feel like a
greater sense of growth if you had that
initial doubt and then no no no I I was
definitely right and now I'm not gonna
give up and now I'm gonna freaking
confront Frank at the dinner table in
front of everybody and be Brazen and not
care you know yeah I would have probably
would have made that moment hit a little
harder if she hadn't committed to like
you know there is something wrong with
me it's not them yeah maybe I will take
my medication yeah yeah yeah no and and
then Frank confronts and then it's like
oh no [ __ ] yeah yeah she's just gotten
back onto no no no I you know what I was
wrong everything's fine and then he
reveals that to her and then it's like
oh no wait what have I done yeah and
then and I think I gotta double down
what what would have helped too is I
think if it if there was like oh now
we're in full rewrite territory it is
that's what we're doing let us man this
place
another draft is what we're doing um
yeah
we're not changing the movie entirely
we're just like no we're we're just
adding a little bit more in there of
what I think could have helped it like
when he is promoted
because what comes before the Frank
unveils you know like he's clueing her
he's letting her know like no you're
right you know
um you're on to something but in private
when he does that scene in the kitchen
between what would have helped between
that is if there was a confrontation I
think between Harry Styles and Florence
Pugh of you know her being like I'm
telling you you know she's going off and
he's saying like this is my big night
this is my promotion and you're making
this about you like like they get into
like a really heated argument and that's
when she can come back to reality of
like I am Savage like she can take on
the blame of like I am sabotaging I'm
sorry I don't mean to I don't mean to do
this you're right this is your big night
I need to support you like if if a
Creator real problem between them the
fact that he was promoted and she wasn't
around for it and she was in her own
[ __ ] world and he's like doing a big
old song yeah and she's not there being
supportive at all it creates a real like
riff in their relationship and that's
what helps Propel her
so it's like all right everything's
gonna be back no all in five let no
let's let's see if Frank can come over
for dinner like it's her idea and then
and then that happens at the dinner yeah
and I'm like oh damn that would have
just made the attention of it Rising it
would have made the relationship between
her and Harry Styles feel that I think
that's what have given that anxiety
thrust sure yeah and because thinking
about that moment I mean in in the
moment I wasn't like ah damn you know
they really missed out on an opportunity
blah blah no I never I was thinking any
of this yeah yeah but during but
thinking back on that sequence it is
like I thought a bigger conflict or
acknowledgment of like you know uh the
thing in the bedroom yeah yeah him like
directly bringing that up those are two
moments yeah like Olivia Wilde in the
bathrooms like it's it's Jack's big day
you're in here you know like you're
thinking about yourself and being a
child and there's never really I don't
really recall much of a acknowledgment
of that situation with Jack much at all
and then yeah you have that whole thing
where he point points out seeing them in
the bedroom
and because it sounds like she she slept
with him sure it sounds like yeah and
you would think that amid all these
different lies and Illusions she would
want to be like no that's not what
happened you know don't try and Gaslight
me further in front of everybody and
make me you discredit me in front of
everybody further I think with this
discussion what I do think is truly
missing from this movie is capturing the
relationship between Florence Pugh and
Harry Styles feeling like the heart and
soul of this movie so that way it feels
very tragic by the end yes and because
because the tragedy doesn't hit you're
waiting for their relationship to
dissolve yeah yeah like the you don't
really buy into it you feel like there's
something just suspicious about him the
whole time something's always wrong and
it's rarely ever like nah this is right
these two belong together yeah you're
like oh maybe he's a good guy you know
it it doesn't feel the tragic parts of
it that want you to feel like the
tragedy don't hit that's why at the very
end I was about to be pissed off with
the movie because it doesn't feel
heartbreaking to me when she's thinking
about the you know her time with him yes
of the choice that I'm Gonna Let It Go
like it doesn't feel heartbreaking to me
at all I'll just be like no you're being
stupid and go you like it yeah
especially with how the reveal is
portrayed where it's just like this this
deadbeat guy kidnaps his girlfriend puts
her in a simulation so that he can have
his ideal life with her well it's like
they mainly just
it's like there's no it's just like
sexual with that man and yeah
it doesn't ever really feel like a real
relationship to me other than you got
actors who are just really going at it
and and they're bonding you know which
in a weird way in a conceptual way I
don't necessarily begrudge the movie for
given what we see of the reality like
clearly you know they make a point in
that seen in the kitchen where he's like
come on I don't want to play around
she's like I've been working for 30
hours you know like and so it makes
sense to me that their relationship
would be so sexual and and that would be
so much of what we wanted but the other
action is not anything it's just so like
but yeah Baseline it's like they had to
have gotten together for a reason in the
real world and I still don't know what
that is because you only see the what
could be construed as positive in the
simulation and thus you don't really I
didn't really get a sense for the
Bedrock of their connection yeah of
their relationship to each other yeah
yeah it felt it felt like they were it
felt like they were paired together it
felt like a lot of these couples were
paired together by somebody else in a
way yeah I know that's why I kept
thinking the flashbacks were like yeah
and maybe that was intentional to make
you feel like oh that's a different yeah
it's not a real husband yeah it was
intentional because it's not the real
him
um but still anyway no it's a fun movie
yeah had fun though I enjoyed it yeah I
enjoyed it I was like yeah too much crap
I had a feeling I wouldn't be as bad as
everyone said yes and yeah I liked it I
liked it no I didn't overall I would say
I liked it and I liked it I liked it
quite a bit I'm excited member of this
movie yeah this will be one of the one
of the films of 2022 I think back on
like yeah I remember this and uh I would
love to see Olivia Wilde Branch out into
more strange surreal genre stuff
like marriage story like marriage story
yeah
I want to see your take on Revolutionary
Road
[Laughter]
how many more references can we pack in
here
what other divorce movies
whatever yeah yeah yeah
there you go there you go uh we miss any
of there any more there's there's some
of that in 10 lasso the movie yes
let's see the really positive version of
this now
in in the movie that's where Frank is
the protagonist he is Ted last time it
sounds like it was a nightmare to put
together and uh
like I thought this isn't this doesn't
feel like a crazy hodgepodge mess like
it definitely doesn't it just feels like
yeah I feel like I could have used
another draft
um but it doesn't feel like oh yeah the
[ __ ] there's a problem
how embarrassing no not at all surprises
are not all right no there's tons of
interesting stuff and there's tons it
feels like if there were problems this
would be the same movie exactly yes no
no no really because it is it is a very
assured and very steady-handed movie you
know it doesn't come across choppy or
anything like that no no or or tonally
imbalanced rushed at times but I think
that's out of your ordinary movie that
happens you know it's your it's her what
second feature film
I think so so you know I've been
impressive yeah all things considered
yeah definitely you know this could have
this could have fallen so much more flat
and it's really courteous of a director
to let your lead actor director yeah
that's right man I don't know what's
true
I will take it that Olivia wild directed
99 of them all right yeah
any any day Harry wasn't on
at least all right guys well what do you
think about don't worry darling leave
your thoughts down below go ahead
subscribe leave a like and uh thank you
to wondery last but not least let's do a
patreon
Tyler Hague Tyler my friend T Hague with
God of War coming out ooh Ragnarok I am
replaying God of War
which I first played on the PS4 he gave
me forever ago oh uh this month I am
wanting to give a special thank you a
proper thank you that's why I want to
say special it's a typical Patron the
day shout out thank you they're all not
not a run-of-the-mill special thank you
yeah there I wanted a a first
highlighting I want to take time to
First highlight the people who have been
here for a very long time you have been
a consistent supporter at our patreon
page for 54 months wow we do the math
John 12 times 4 is 48. 12 times 4 is 48.
it's like a year and a half yes that's
right
oh no every time we fall into this trap
yes yes 12 times 4 is 48 and there's 12
months in a year so we it'd be uh four
and a half years four and a half years
yeah I said a year and a half yeah yeah
man I was thinking four and a half of my
head don't don't confuse me like that
don't take me back to thinking it's
weeks no no it's four and a half yeah um
four and a half years man that's a long
ass time thank you for being here for so
long and for never swaying from us
it's insane to have people like you at
our page and seriously
you should make it you should make a
trip to California Los Angeles dude I
know you were out here once but you were
way far away and we couldn't make it so
come to directly right you gotta go like
10 minutes away from us yes that will
make time come to a beautiful downtown
don't pass like 15 minutes traffic to
rain and then it could be like a half
hour and you know just be a little too
busy yes no man you gotta you gotta you
gotta come back out here and and um
we're better at making time for special
occasions like this so please
make another trip out here what the [ __ ]
are we gonna do in Wisconsin
yeah man there's not there's only so
many of this tree by your home look at
this tree we'll buy some Packers
souvenirs no no yeah we'll go visit Red
Letters wasted time you know that but
that's all in an afternoon what else are
we gonna do thank you for being you
Tyler you're amazing I love you love you
so much
bye you plated nachos when I see him oh
laughs